supporters of Gustavo Petro March
through Bogota to mark 100 days of the
country's first ever leftist president
some of Petro's loftier Ambitions have
been quietly dialed back as the
government faces the realities of
soaring inflation and a gaping fiscal
deficit but for those here Petro's
promise of change remains intact
we're very happy with what has been
accomplished in these hundred days he is
trying to fulfill what he has proposed
obviously some things need to be revised
but we remain steadfast that chain can
be achieved to ensure governability and
try to assuage Market fears Petro has
managed to build a broad Coalition in
congress with the traditional parties he
often criticized
a strategy that allowed him to pass a 20
billion dollar fiscal Bill raising taxes
on fossil fuels in the rich to finance
social programs he's also instituted a
total peace law to start negotiations
with all remaining guerillian
paramilitary groups in the country and
an unprecedented deal with Colombia's
powerful cattle ranching Association to
buy 3 million hectares of land to
redistribute to poor farmers
in a press conference on Wednesday
surrounded by his cabinet Petro
presented a list of 50 achievements he
says Point towards greater political and
social justice
politics today are not divided by left
and right the division is among policies
that Empower life and those that
extinguish it and foreign policy has
spearheaded an international campaign to
change drug policy and fight climate
change while also restarting relations
with neighboring Venezuela after years
of tension but his government also faces
growing criticism on his economic
messaging his ministers making
contradictory announcements about ending
oil and gas exploration which many
observers blame for the fall of the
local currency the peso against the
dollar petrol is doing the job that he
was elected to do he did campaign for
changes and he is proposing new ideas
what I don't like is his government's
announcements on the economy and how
they intend and to manage the economy
they change every day the government's
policies on the oil sector on new
contracts on exploration have caused the
markets to Whirlwind but despite these
missteps Petra's approval ratings remain
strong with half the country supporting
its Administration and polls that's 20
points higher than its predecessor at
this point which means Petro still has a
large political Capital to spend as it
tries to advance in transforming one of
the most unequal countries on Earth